as the head of idea nikivation at lnd I
am driving Innovative and futuristic
product growth for various Technologies
and blockchain is one of the
Technologies
courses helped me to identify various
business use cases and how to use this
technology in the real business
scenarios
and I think it will also help me to
identify the right talent for my company
hey I am bgpk I had the idea and
integration team at LED I live in
Chennai
some time back I decided to build an
integration program based on blockchain
technology
it's supposed to be a challenge since I
knew very little about a blockchain
Technologies
when you are working at this position
you should know little about everything
you cannot be black right so I decided
to take a certificate program in
blockchain from IED Contour offered by
simply land and the courses helped me
immensely
again
good conceptual and Architectural
knowledge on the emerging blockchain
technology and go to Hands-On knowledge
working knowledge on the blockchain
technology and get to know about the
overall blockchain ecosystems so with
that now I am able to develop a
blockchain technology products as a
result my work has advanced
significantly and my expertise on
designing Innovative products really
benefited I will also be hiring for
blockchain based projects
and my knowledge on blockchain will be
helpful in scouting the right talent for
the company
not to forget the overall the experience
of this course was mic
and there's a flexible schedule really
helped me to balance my work at studies
my years of experience made me realize
that hard work and knowledge never go in
me
so you should keep challenging yourself
and learn new things